Whatever system you choose to build your
game, take advantage of the objects and
patterns it provides to decouple
the pieces and simplify development.
These might be special abstract data
types that hide private data, or
a type safe way to pass
messages between game objects.
There might be a built-in mechanism to
create actors or items in the world, or
maybe even behaviors that can
be attached to these objects.
The system might provide object pooling
to automatically recycle unused items
and optimize memory usage.
If you're using a game engine or library
that includes features like these,
they can greatly speed development and
usually end up making your code
more robust in the process.
You don't have to build these
components from scratch, and
you don't have to debug them usually.
Even if you're not using
a game development framework,
the programming language you choose may
offer features that can help you create
solid game code.
Type safety, object-oriented features
like classes and interfaces.
Private data access,
threat synchronization mechanisms,
memory management,
standard collection types.
These are all useful features that
can reduce your coding burden.